[Musik]
tod und zerstörung in beirut mindestens
135 menschen sterben durch die gewaltige
explosion in der libanesischen
hauptstadt
die krankenhäuser sind hoffnungslos
überlastet nun doch ein geständnis im
mordfall walter lübke gibt der
hauptangeklagte stefan herrn zu selbst
geschossen zu haben keine nachsicht mit
masken muffel
wer in nordrhein-westfalen in bus und
bahn ohne mundschutz unterwegs ist muss
künftig sofort 150 euro zahlen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten an diesem mittwoch
norbert lehmann ist für den sport an
meiner seite
beirut steht unter schock
es ist der tag nach der verheerenden
explosion wie gestern abend große teile
der stadt verwüstet hat mindestens 135
menschen sind gestorben etwa 5000
verletzt worden
wie viele menschen noch in und unter den
trümmern liegen ist unklar
die explosion ereignete sich in einer
lagerhalle im hafen von beirut
dort lagerte offenbar tonnenweise
ammoniumnitrat hochexplosiv die
druckwelle zerstörte sämtliche gebäude
in der nähe komplett selbst häuser in
mehreren kilometern entfernung wurden
beschädigt mindestens 250.000 menschen
sind wohl obdachlos selbst aus 20
kilometern entfernten orten wurden noch
schäden gemeldet
julia schröter berichtet der tag danach
im hafen von beirut viel ist nicht übrig
geblieben außer chaos und rauchenden
trümmern
immer noch suchen helfer nach
überlebenden das ist eine nationale
katastrophe
bei rot ist eine zerstörte stadt wir
müssen jetzt stark und tapfer sein sagte
gouverneur und bricht in tränen aus
gestern 18 uhr ortszeit erst brennt ist
dann eine starke explosion mit einer
gigantischen druckwelle die über die
stadt rollt selbst 200 kilometer
entfernt in zypern ist sie noch zu
spüren
die wucht der explosion schleuderte
fahrzeuge durch die luft reißt menschen
von den füßen
ich hörte einen knall und ging raus um
zu gucken während ich in den himmel
schaute kam die explosion
ich wurde zurück ins zimmer geschleudert
ich sah wie meine frau blutete sie war
am kopf getroffen worden
ganze stadtviertel sehen aus wie nach
einem bombenangriff ist es halt so dass
es immer noch teile diese zugänglich
sind teile von bayern und das immer noch
leute geborgen
es ist auch so dass zb leute in den
krankenhäusern noch abgewiesen werden
weil halt einfach nicht genug herzen
nicht genug betten zur verfügung stehen
ermittler suchen nun nach der ursache
für die schwere explosion
nach angaben der libanesischen regierung
lagerten im hafen fast 3000 tonnen
ammoniumnitrat seit jahren und
ungesichert ammoniumnitrat ist ein
weißes pulver
es kann als düngemittel verwendet werden
man kann aber auch sprengstoff daraus
herstellen
bei großer hitze oder kontakt mit einer
flamme kann ammoniumnitrat explodieren
was auch immer die detonation ausgelöst
haben mag die bewohner von beirut müssen
nun mit den folgen leben hunderttausende
haben ihr zuhause verloren
fragen wir uli gack unseren nahost
korrespondenten oder wie kann es sein
dass tausende tonnen eines so exklusiven
stoffs über jahre am hafen lagern ohne
dass sich jemand darum kümmert sich
niemand darum gekümmert hat das wissen
will ich es ist eine reichlich nebulöse
sache hat man diese 2007 möglicherweise
vergessen verschlammt oder hat sie eine
dieser verfeindeten
religionsgemeinschaften zurückgelegt
gebunkert für zeiten in denen eben
sprengstoffe gilt der konjunktur haben
momentan beginnt die suche nach den
schuldigen einige hafenmitarbeiter
wurden auf hausarrest gesetzt eine
unabhängige internationale
expertenkommission soll im auftrag der
libanesischen regierung die sache
untersuchen
man setzt nicht auf eigene leute weil
die regierung weiß wenn libanesen diese
untersuchung durchführen wenn wir die
bevölkerung diese sache nicht glauben es
ist ein großes misstrauen großer
vertrauensverlust innerhalb der
bevölkerung zwischen der regierung im
libanon ist im prinzip derzeit fast
alles möglich eben auch was diese
sprengstoffe betrifft momentan ist die
sache lieber nebulös und wir stehen am
anfang von den gesamten untersuchungen
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung uniqa
kraters vor ein paar jahrzehnten war der
libanon ein hoch attraktives land mit
florierender wirtschaft und dem charme
des orients ein begehrtes reiseziel
heute steht das land am abgrund die
menschen leiden und der arbeitslosigkeit
armut und korruption
und dann kam auch noch die pandemie
anselm stern
stockdunkel sind die nächte im libanon
viele stunden lang fällt der strom aus
immer wieder in weiten teilen des landes
die grundversorgung funktioniert nicht
mehr
der libanon ist quasi bankrott die
schwerste wirtschaftskrise seit 30
jahren mindestens 45 prozent der
bevölkerung gelten als arm
35 prozent sind arbeitslos in den 50er
und 60er jahren galt der libanon als
schweiz des nahen ostens etwa wegen der
einst mächtigen banken tolerant liberal
so anders als viele nachbarstaaten
doch von diesem glanz ist nicht viel
übrig seit dem ende des bürgerkriegs
1990 sitzen wieder viele verschiedene
religionsgemeinschaften zusammen am
regierungstisch ein system des
ausgleichs sollte es werden es wurde ein
system der korruption
das libanesische pfund ist jetzt im
freien fall
wenn die regierung nicht endlich anfängt
zu erklären wenn sie nicht endlich
anfängt die international und national
zugesagten reformprogramme umzusetzen
dann wird die bevölkerung wieder auf der
straße stehen und ich denke dann ist
nicht auszuschließen dass auch diese
regierung fällt so wie die
vorgängerregierung vorhanden
die menschen wehren sich im herbst 2009
10 demonstrierten hunderttausende gegen
die ungerechtigkeit gegen die mächtigen
in beirut aber der protest wurde
aufgehalten zum teil von prügelnden
banden und von der korona krise die ja
auch noch wütet im krisenstaat libanon
zur katastrophe von bj senden wir auch
ein zdf spezial um 19.20 direkt nach den
heute -nachrichten die aktuelle
entwicklung nach der verheerenden
explosion haben wir auch online in
unserer app und aufsätze erfreute zum
prozess um den mord an dem kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
da hat heute der hauptangeklagte stefan
ernst ein geständnis abgelegt er habe
den tödlichen schuss abgegeben und er
belastete seinen mutmaßlichen komplizen
marcus h der habe ihn angestachelt
politisch radikalisiert und er sei bei
der tat dabei gewesen
susanna santina mit den details
der prozess heute war eine zäsur nicht
nur dass der hauptangeklagte stefan
ernst zum ersten mal vor gericht fragen
beantwortete in einer einlassung die
sein anwalt verlas gestand er dass er
den tödlichen schuss auf walter lübke
abgefeuert hatte außerdem so ernst soll
markus h in der tat nach dabei gewesen
sein
die bundesanwaltschaft bleibt skeptisch
ob das klarheit bringt ob das
letztendlich der wahrheit entspricht
das wird man erst am ende der
beweisaufnahme unter umständen sehen
können für eine bewirtung ist es derzeit
noch zu früh
schon bei seiner ersten vernehmung hatte
stefan ernst die tat gestanden
in einer zweiten dann aber markus h
beschuldigt in der nacht zum 2 juni 2009
10 den tödlichen schuss auf den
politiker walter lübke abgefeuert zu
haben versehentlich so stefan ernst
damals
jetzt sagt er dass markus hameter
gewesen sei der den mord mit ihm lange
geplant habe
der anwalt von markus erhält das wir
unglaubwürdig es hat er wieder was
anderes erzählt
da wird man vielleicht auch mal
irgendwann erfahren oder auch nicht auf
wen er jetzt gehört habt stefan ernst
sprach in seiner einlassung heute von
seinem vater der alkoholiker gewesen sei
und ihn und die mutter immer wieder
geschlagen hätte für die familie von
walter lübke sei das schwer zu ertragen
gewesen so ihr sprecher sieht das auch
zerreißt zb hören zu müssen wenn in
weiten teilen der hauptangeklagte sich
als opfer einer schwierigen kindheit
darstellt als opfer von radikalisierung
am freitag will sich stefan ernst zu
weiteren fragen äußern nur fragen der
anwälte von marcus h will er nicht
beantworten
es ist die dritte version von stefan
ernst
felix zimmermann aus unserer redaktion
recht und justiz beobachtet den prozess
im oberlandesgericht frankfurt felix wie
glaubwürdig ist dieses neue geständnis
ja sie sagen es ist es die dritte tat
version die stefan ernst hier schildert
deswegen sind an die beurteilung und
bewertung seiner glaubwürdigkeit immer
höchste zweifel angebracht
da er nun erneut eingestanden hat weiter
lücke erschossen zu haben
bestehen an seiner täterschaft keine
vernünftigen zweifel mehr
das große rätselraten betrifft die
person des marcus h ob es zutrifft dass
dieser am tatort war ist davon ernst
behauptet und die zutat anstachelte etwa
mit den worten wenn lipp geblüht kommt
dann schießt du zwar hat ernst
widerspruchsfrei erläutert dass markus h
für ihn eine rechtsextremistische
leitfigur war aber auch heute wieder
spricht er sich teilweise sagte etwa
dass marcus h mit am tatort war und ihn
aufgefordert hat zu schießen dann
plötzlich sei es aber nur abgemacht
gewesen lücke einzuschüchtern
von daher sieht die
generalbundesanwaltschaft
generalbundesanwalt auch keine beweise
für eine mittäterschaft von markus haag
und hat die nur wegen beihilfe angeklagt
ob es dabei bleibt wenn die weiteren
verhandlungstage hier in frankfurt
zeigen und die beobachten sich hier uns
vielen dank dafür
felix
schauen wir auf die entwicklung der
korona infektion in deutschland da gibt
es weiter einen leichten anstieg im
durchschnitt der letzten sieben tage
haben sich täglich 730 menschen mit dem
virus infiziert gestern waren es noch
710 wegen der steigenden corona zahlen
wollen jetzt mehrere bundesländer
verstöße gegen die masken pflicht in
bussen und bahnen härter bestrafen wer
keine mund nasen maske trägt muss
künftig etwa in nordrhein westfalen
schon beim ersten vergehen sofort 150
euro bußgeld bezahlen
auch schleswig holstein und
niedersachsen wollen solche verstöße
konsequent ahnden
dominik müller sl berichtet hamburg
hauptbahnhof heute mit
[Musik]
auf dem bahnhof
das jeder gerne
anfahren
[Musik]
wir sind nicht viele aber eben doch ein
paar menschen die entweder keine maske
auf haben oder die maske nicht richtig
tragen
in nordrhein westfalen sollen solche
verstöße nun teuer werden und es wird
nicht mehr lange diskutiert sondern
direkt geahndet wir wollen ein bußgeld
von 150 euro auch nicht erst nach
ansprache und langen diskussionen wir
hören von den praktikern dass es viel zu
viele inzwischen drauf ankommen lassen
und dann ganz überrascht tun aber die
maske sofort zu handhaben ist eine frage
der bequemlichkeit geworden und das kann
es nicht sein
noch nicht ganz klar ist wie sich die
neue verordnung umsetzen lässt dann nur
das ordnungsamt und die polizei solche
bußgelder verhängen dürfen nicht aber
die normalen kontrolleure der
verkehrsbetriebe viele fahrgäste
begrüßen und wünschen sich ein
konsequenteres vorgehen
ich begrüße es auf jeden fall beispiel
berufspendler also ich bin auf bahn und
bus und straßenbahn angewiesen
tagtäglich und es lebe das halt oft dass
viele leute das auf die leichte schulter
nehmen und muss ganz ehrlich sagen finde
ich gar nicht gut ich bin letztens mit
öffentlichen gefahren das war sehr voll
kein kontrolleur ließ sich blicken viele
ohne maske gegessen
die leute berühren einander und da fände
ich glaube ich schon gut wenn da ein
bisschen härtere strafen verhängt werden
was die muschel sind den bussen und
bahnen nicht bekommen in nordrhein
westfalen will man sich jetzt noch
entschlossener zeigt
die schwer gebeutelte deutsche
autoindustrie schöpft hoffnung die
nachfrage zieht wieder an
nach einem desaströsen ersten halbjahr
wurden im juli fast so viele autos neu
zugelassen wie im vorjahresmonat
deutlich mehr kunden als bisher
entscheiden sich für einen elektromotor
darüber steigt das interesse allerdings
noch das angebot der deutschen
hersteller
elisabeth schmidt berichtet noch
schrauben martina bruns und ihr team am
passat doch statt verbrennen sollen hier
im volkswagen werk emden künftig 300.000
elektro autos pro jahr vom band rollen
es für riesenchance für uns natürlich
hat man ängste dass das die fahrzeuge
sich durchsetzen dass die technologie
dann auch die richtige ist und ja dass
wir wettbewerbsfähig sind
hier sollen die mitarbeiter in etwa zwei
jahren den id vier montieren einen
elektrischen suv unklar ist wie viele
arbeitsplätze abgebaut werden
denn bei der produktion von e autos
werden deutlich weniger teile verbaut
ich denke 30 bis 40 prozent der
arbeitsinhalte fallen werk in gänze
inklusive der komponenten
aber es kommen bestimmt auch 15 bis 20
prozent wieder dazu bis jahresende
herrscht bei volkswagen erst einmal
einstellungsstopp eine folge der korona
krise insgesamt erholt sich der
automobilmarkt langsam das zeigt der
vergleich mit dem vergangenen jahr
315.000 neuzulassungen im juli fast wie
2009/10 darunter auch 17.000 reine
elektrofahrzeuge ein plus von 182
prozent im vergleich zum vorjahresmonat
hybride also verbrenner mit zusätzlichem
elektromotor legten um 144 prozent zu
die milliardenverluste durch die korona
krise zwingen die autobauer ihre
investitionen jetzt genau abzuwägen es
könnte dazu führen dass corona er die
transformation richtung elektromobilität
verstärkt weil die automobilhersteller
eben jetzt ihre forschungs und
entwicklungsausgaben auf diese neuen
themen wie e mobilität konzentrieren
martina bruns oft dass elektroautos auch
volkswagen aus der krise fahren
sie ihren arbeitsplatz behält während
und nach dem zweiten weltkrieg verloren
millionen menschen durch flucht und
vertreibung ihr zuhause
daran erinnert jedes jahr der bund der
vertriebenen
am mittag wurde mit einer
kranzniederlegung in stuttgart an eine
vor 70 jahren verkündete charta erinnert
in ihr ist festgeschrieben dass die
vertriebenen auf rache und vergeltung
verzichten sonne strand meer und
waldbrände
damit müssen urlauber in südfrankreich
auch in diesem sommer rechnen
in der nähe von marseille brennt es an
mehreren stellen 2700 menschen
verbrachten die nacht in notunterkünften
annafest berichtet das ist alles was von
diesem campingplatz an der französischen
mittelmeerküste übrig geblieben ist
in den überresten stehen obdachlose
touristen
gestern waren wir noch am strand dort
schlafen wir dort unser campingwagen und
heute zur selben zeit sieht es so aus
das haut einen um bilder von gestern
nachmittag 1800 einsatzkräfte versuchen
das feuer in griff zu bekommen
wir standen hinter dem fenster und
deshalb geraucht ganz viel rauch und
dann ging alles in flammen auf alles
brannte und der wind trieb dann alles
weiter nach da und buch 2700 menschen
müssen ihre unterkunft verlassen
beeilen sie sich wir müssen hier noch
andere rausholen
die flucht es teilweise nur mit boten
möglich viele harren in notunterkünften
wie diesen aus darunter auch ein
deutsches pärchen interviewt von einem
französischen sender
wir waren am kochen und dann kam sie und
sagten wir sollten los so schnell wie
möglich sie sagten nimmt nur das
nötigste mit geht nicht ins auto fahrt
nicht weggeht zum strand dort wurden wir
in die busse gesetzt und hierher
gefahren
eine region im ausnahmezustand
noch gibt es keine entwarnung es brennt
weiter auch an diesem nachmittag zum
sport zu norbert und zum restart der
fußball gucken ja heute anders
achtelfinal-rückspiel von wolfsburg in
bonn jetzt in kiew morgen müssen
frankfurt in basel und leverkusen zu
hause gegen glasgow rangers ran
die cola pandemie hat einiges im
europapokal durcheinandergebracht auch
den austragungsmodus nach fünf monaten
pause wieder europapokal vor vor den
leverkusen vor morgigen spiel gegen die
glasgow rangers auswärtssieg im hinspiel
das finalturnier zum greifen nah
natürlich haben wir eine sehr gute
ausgangsposition
das muss man sagen der mal auswärts 3 1
gewinnt dann ist das gut aber so einfach
wird das nicht sein denn der heimvorteil
ist keiner gespielt wird ohne zuschauer
und eva mit weiteren corona
vorsichtsmaßnahmen inter mailand gestern
auf anreise nach gelsenkirchen auf
neutralen schalker rasen ko-spiel gegen
christopher alle wollen zum finalturnier
ab der kommenden woche nordrhein
westfalen das land hat von eva den
zuschlag bekommen aufgrund niedriger
corona fallzahlen gespielt wird in vier
stadien
die herausforderung für die trainer aber
ist immens vorher reach es ist für jeden
trainer schwierig diese kurze zeit von
erholung und die vorbereitung zu managen
ich habe das noch nie erleben vor das
ist neu und eine große herausforderung
die challenge das ziel ist klar das
finale steigt am 21 august in köln
rafael nadal hat seine teilnahme an den
us open ende august abgesagt der
vorjahressieger und tennis
weltranglistenzweite begründete dies mit
den steigenden corona zahlen nadal ist
nicht der erste spieler der das
renommierte turnier in new york meidet
er ist lichtet sich das feld bei den us
open
pastor faehling mein gefühl mein herz
sagt mir dass sich momentan lieber nicht
so weit reisen möchte
vor ihm hatten bereits mit kürbis und
die weltranglisten-erste ersparte ihre
teilnahme abgesagt und es könnten noch
einige folgen
ich habe mit meinem team entschieden
dass ich mich vorbereitet körperlich und
sportlich
jetzt würde ich die us open spielen und
dann kurz vor schluss sozusagen eine
entscheidung treffen ob ich dann diese
risiken mit dem reisen und amerika auf
mich nehmen würde oder nicht
eine schwierige situation und nur zwei
wochen später sollen die french open
volk das war es auch schon früher
entscheiden
und wir haben noch die lottozahlen für
sie die gewinnzahlen lauten 6 18 24 33
42 und die superzahl 4 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und in zdf text auf seite 55 7
der hochsommer kommt etwas später als
erwartet und er bleibt so wie es
aussieht sonne und eine hitze die sich
von tag zu tag steigert details hat
gleich katja horneffer so viel von uns
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
das heute-journal später mit marietta
slomka und wir sehen uns morgen abend
wieder punkt 19 uhr ihnen noch einen
guten abend hier geht es jetzt weiter
mit dem spezial zu der tragödie in
beirut
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
hoch detlef wird eingerahmt durch einige
teams im norden und ein tief im süden
und es bringt uns in den nächsten tagen
sehr hohe temperaturen und viel
sonnenschein
heute gab es nur kleine quellwolken und
nur in der grenze zu dänemark auch mal
ein paar dichtere wolken und die gibt es
jetzt auch in der nacht sonst ist es
meist klar und die temperaturen sinken
auf 17 grad am niederrhein oder auch auf
den ostfriesischen inseln deutlich
kühler wird zum beispiel im vogtland mit
acht grad oder auch am alpenrand mit
sieben grad da ist dann morgen auch die
sommerwärme noch so ein bisschen
gedämpft da steigen die werte nämlich
nur bis 24 grad sonst peilen sie doch
aber überall die 30 grad marke an und am
wärmsten wird es morgen hier zwischen
dem münsterland den niederrhein und dem
rhein-main-gebiet mit 32 bis 34 grad und
dazu strahlt die sonne der wind weht nur
schwach und die schattenspendenden
wolken sind wirklich nur selten und das
bleibt auch so in den nächsten tagen bei
höchsttemperaturen am freitag von 26 bis
36 grad am samstag von 27 bis 38 grad
und am sonntag bei 27 bis 35 kraft da
kann ich ihnen doch nur schöne
sommerabende wünschen